nantes ville sexy pas du tout c'est du
moins l'avis d'un sondage paru cette
semaine dans l'événement du jeudi
alors est ce la vérité c'est ce qu'ont
voulu savoir pascal praud et benoît
labourdette nantes dans le congélateur
du hit-parade sexy des 99 villes de
france nantes glacée à la 72e place au
milieu d'un grand ouest tout aussi
réfrigérée angers 62e et la timbale pour
le mans 90e et pourtant froid nantes
jamais regardé ce que j'ai trouvé la
petite culotte et la combine et c'est
super mais c'est très très cher 1150
francs c'est difficile d'être sexy non
non je trouve pas nantes n'est pas une
ville très sexy nantais sang froid
plutôt pour les gens
je vous demande d'en lever quelque chose
vous le faites
oui je veux bien qu est ce que vous
comprenez par sexy sexy
[Musique]
c'est
sans taxer si je sais pas non non je ne
comprends pas lancé rien si vous voulez
que j'en avais ou mentaux je l'espère
vous pouvez demander beaucoup
[Musique]
je peux pas de publicité mais bon il ya
plein de ya pleinement il s'est un petit
peu plus discret que dans le sud de la
france mais il faut savoir faut savoir
découvrir les nantaises alors c'est
entendu dans ce n'est pas véritablement
une ville très sexy puis on sait jamais
c'est peut-être des choses qui peuvent
s'arranger
il ne comptait pas sur moi pour me
déshabiller devant la caméra
[Musique]